(grunts)
TORI:
I think that we kind of
take for granted
the amount of knowledge
and experience that we have
when we're heading out
into the backcountry.
For us, it might just kind of
be your regular adventure
but for others,
it's a huge endeavor
and, and scary
and there's a lot to learn.
JIM:
I can't believe that we just
rolled in here just before dark
and found a gorgeous campsite.
-(Wesley giggling)
-TORI: Wes, you are in
a very good mood this morning.
This one, on the other hand,
this one... is up to no good.
(Huddy gurgling)
Ow!
JIM:
Water's boiling, honey.
TORI:
Do you just wanna
do oatmeal this morning?
JIM:
Yeah, yeah.
It's oatmeal or no-meal
in these parts.
TORI:
For Wesley's meals
in the backcountry,
because of his low muscle tone,
he isn't able
to chew efficiently.
So, we puree all of his food
or give him as much soft,
mashable food as possible.
It can be a little bit
more challenging
if we are trying to live off
the land as much as possible.
Foraging for foods
and things like that for him,
we do have to make sure
it's something
that he's gonna be able
to eat, first of all,
and also it's gonna be
easy on his tummy.
JIM:
I think Wesley is just
responding so well
to being in nature.
But I think he's
also just happy
to spend more
quality time with us.
He just seems to be,
you know,
more engaged
with his surrounding.
Don't you Wes, huh?
You little champion,
my best bud. Yes you are!
(Wesley and Huddy murmur)
So that was some
pretty good feedback
we got from
the physiotherapist
about just getting
Wesley outdoors?
TORI:
Totally. And I think
it'll be a great thing
to prepare him
for going to school.
'Cause he's starting school
pretty much
right when we get back.
JIM:
I'm probably gonna cry
when we drop him off at school.
-TORI: Oh, yeah. For sure.
-JIM: 'Cause our special
little boy,
he can't really communicate
and it's a big day for him.
He's gonna make some friends,
he's gonna learn,
you know, they have
devices for him there
that we can't really fit
in our house.
But, I think it's gonna be great
for his development
and for him
to make some friends.
TORI:
He's never really been
away from us for that--
-JIM: No he hasn't. No.
-TORI: That long.
You know what I mean?
JIM:
Your brother's gonna
go to school
-and then learn stuff.
-(Huddy babbles)
TORI:
As far as when we
one day live off-grid,
unless we're prepared to do
some serious homeschooling
for him and Hudson--
JIM:
Yeah so that's the other thing,
homeschooling is
a lot of work as well.
We'll find a way
to make it work, you know?
-TORI: Yeah.
-JIM: We'll find a way
to do both things.
TORI:
When we first started dating
there was this romanticized
fantasy of living off-grid
in a log cabin
in the middle of nowhere,
which sounded beautiful.
But, having Wesley now
and his needs,
I do worry about
living there full-time.
I'm excited about it,
I'm nervous.
I think that I'm just more
of the logistical person
when it comes to the kids.
I don't wanna be
irresponsible with it.
taking Wesley,
who does have
these complex needs,
so far away from help.
To start, I'm really
looking forward
to having that
off-grid property
that we can go to
a couple times a year
and gradually make it home.
JIM:
(whistles) North,
time to do dishes.
(North barks)